hier leute bevor sie ausgebildet noch
zwei kurze ansage und zwar ist die erste
aufgabe auf spartacus deswegen
öffentlich alles so rund man auch mal
ein paar leise und ich habe jetzt in den
stunden gesessen den einzelnen taten dem
er gesprochen hat lauter gemacht und vom
mega viel arbeit die calli ist trotzdem
nicht so und ich hab aber ich habe
wirklich viel mühe gegeben
ich hoffe könnte es entschuldigen und
zweitens habe ich jetzt bevor das alles
eigentlich video so ein versuch
geschnitten wohl heftig getadelt worden
war zeigen wollte wie das ist und mit
zwei youtube nicht gelegt auf
kammerspielen
du hast echt lustig deswegen würde ich
sagen viel spaß mit dem video an
ich hab' ich bin spät raus geworfen
servus s kids sind willkommen zu einer
neuen folge better together heute mit
dem lieben aber ein bisschen kränkelt
den job von eine art und wir spielen auf
sg team ist so weil wir uns hier
so dass wir wieder da weder sp 4
ich habe keine ansage wird nicht geraten
reisen studiert hast du das volk ich dir
mal zum hangar in oder hinten waren ja
marino ich hab ne holz holz hose was
sagen für dich jetzt für eisenwaren
fächern stick finden gleich wissen gold
hose für dich ist das lang neben ja hier
komme ich immer raus ich boxe mal eben
alles klar
hoffen wir mal dass ich jetzt ja keine
treppe keiner gegen alle safety du
rechts rein ich gelesen also rechte
seite wo ich eigentlich wert auf sixx
noch ein schwert junges alter das ist
schon mal ein guter start
du hast materialwert oder aber keine
sticks mainz so aber hast du auch selbst
ein schwert ja theoretisch drei
eisenstädter ich gerechnet
ich kann nicht sein dass jeder nicht
serie wird ich hoffe man hört es nicht
allzu sehr dass mein mitbewohner zum
hintergrund mit putzfimmel hat und du
hörst du irgendwann der mist gar nicht
wie lange wir das showprogramm das ist
wichtig teure wohnungen helfe und eltern
beim putzen mit ihrem kollegen und
allein und muss dann irgendwie gucken
wie er klar kommt und deswegen ruhig mal
ein bisschen oder wir stellen kurz in
die ecke und du passt kurz auf dann sage
ich mir einfach dass er kurz pause
machen so ok dann wieder zurück in den
hangar ich stell mich da hinten rein
da ist obsolet aus okay alles klar
soja gebrauch ich brauche dann habe ich
ganz bewusst ein bisschen vorgehen beim
kampf ich kann ab und vielleicht die
puristen ist leer
dreieinhalb ich gehe kurz an meinen
lieblings tue dies noch heute
reis wagen bisschen kopf drin gewesen im
kopf weil das schon helm müssen jetzt
die ganzen leute mensch gerade eben
konnten sich nicht genug bekommen und
jetzt ich bin gerade im haus drin mal
kurz gold harnisch für dich dass man
doch einfach mal ich freue mich schon ab
du bist ja ich habe einen stick für dich
er geht nach vorne der petenten
klassiker ich versuche mir den weg
abzuschneiden das bisschen weit vorne
er hat aber nächstes heißt er ist
eigentlich ein leichtes opfer
ok habe noch nicht gegeben ich verstehe
auch nicht warum er
ok gomez bm dafür einfach vorne anders
sein team-kollege ich wusste dass da
irgendwas vorhat ist weil es eigentlich
klar so den erst mal auseinander ich
habe dreieinhalb herzen
ich drehe mal kurz ab aber bleiben noch
hinter dem geht es gut ich jetzt hier
vorne
es freut mich zu sehen
denken sie es nicht sich gerade ist
gerade da habe ich ihn auch sehr gut als
der user arpu aber gut dann habe ich für
dich tschechien vertreten ein geschenk
wunderbar ja die hunde läuft sehr gut ja
so kann es einfach mal gehen nachdem
jetzt stundenlang gequält haben
funktioniert einfach mal was haben uns
redlich verdient würdig sein käfer mit
ihnen auch in der affen aufnahme jetzt
auch schon natürlich aber der captain
der kapitän der ich gehe ich ihn formal
zum sparen
dann folgen sie ihm der essay meisten
probleme darin müsste in richtung
angaben würden und ein grade so zwei
leute irgendwie seien ja dann tagt noch
mal den tritt verlieben kann ich mir
vorstellen
ich versuche dem abschneiden king auch
mit einem schwert schild mit einer angel
hat kam ich in flammen setzen
flemming verriet er hat irgendwie ganz
gut risse und schaltet das eisen schwert
er ist vorüber ich bitte dich mit all
ihren begrüßen
obst erwartet alter junge was ist denn
mit dem los angeles mich verarschen
leichte hex er hat sich dass ich richtig
komisch geht bei mir der dabei vor allem
auch so ein triple hat gegeben einfach
ja wenn die hat er auch gleich
ausgegeben
der hat der harz während eltern gut an
athen gegeben
ja selbst was machen wir mit dem amigo
erzählen herzen hasst 4 warten will kann
jason das sehen ja dass der sieg der
center nicht behalten wie kommen ihre
aufgaben der punktgewinn punkt mit der
ich glaube gar nicht mehr kämpfen hat er
so ein landschaftsgärtnerischen auftrag
hier so bis hin dass hinter das zeug
bisschen ansehnlicher zu machen mit dem
feuer mein text fx das feuer auch lila
das macht alles ob sie cool
die frage ist halt wie kommst du an
jemanden der da gibt der so gut gas ist
irgendwann leer
irgendwann ja wird sich da vielleicht
selbst von hinten ist ja sehr schön
alles klar so machen wir das
grüße dich dessen treuer kollege
ich hab noch zwei coolsten skin
überhaupt den schwarzen irgendwas warum
nehme ich denn nicht das verzaubert
warum
die alten haus nach oben beginnt gleich
mal gucken wie ich mich schlagen werden
ich wünsche dir alles gute
danke danke danke für die unterstützung
das war wirklich wichtig ich musste mich
herum nicken jetzt kurz war ich sofort
klar geworden bin ich mich aus dem
straßenkinder oder als es dann tot
fungiert das hat auch gut geklappt
ich meine ein genialer schachzug da
müssen noch nutzen gott apfel gegessen
habe ich kann ich gleich ordentlich
fertig machen indes nicht lena oh mein
gott ich weiß nicht wohin soll ich
glaube erst mal weg rocket vergeudet der
days auch durchaus gefährlich mit gold
wert ok ok dann lasst das wollen wir
wollen machen
ich schreibe einfach kurz und trotzdem
tippen nicht bzw 2 nase wenn ein
doppelpunkt schreibst oder groß ok bist
du voll ja noch noch von gestern so
wirklich und ja deine also war gut auf
jeden fall ihr könnt jason king lpa khk
art in der beschreibung abchecken wird
der erste link sein
auf dem channel findet ja auch eine
ungeschnitten folge die wir zusammen
aufgenommen haben und über tage
eigentlich ein paar tagen dann
übertragen das heißt dem schillerpreis
folgen und dann so was macht ihr ja ich
drück dir erstmal ordentlich ein
bisschen aber egal das macht mir nichts
ja getroffen
ich bin so richtig gut möglich geil
hostessen scheiße aber knapp übers alter
du kannst wird unter anderem gene alter
israelis getötet
also das gerne daumen nach oben da
schreibt in die kommentare
ob er mit dem dom sehen wollt werdet ihr
auf jeden fall tun und dann zum nächsten